Voici ce qu'a préparé
Sophie Langlois.
(chorale)
- Au cégep de Drummondville,
les jeunes du programme de
musique viennent d'un peu
partout au Québec, du Nouveau-
Brunswick, même de la France.
Mais l'an dernier, ils étaient
surtout devant leur ordinateur
à la maison.
(solfège)
Les leçons de solfège à distance
sont un défi, même pour les
meilleures oreilles musicales.
VIKTORIA GAGNON, étudiante en
musique, cégDuDuDuDurmmondville
- Si ton zoom, il bogue,
ça bogue puis tu ne peux pas
continuer vraiment le cours. Tu
peux pas en entendre précisément
elleuuuù, l'erreur.
- Est-ce que tu as édedededes
cours, ou tu en as abandonné?
- Oui, oui, j'ai échoué des
cours.
- Est-ce que tu as, à un moment
donné, été découragée au point
de songer de juste abandonner
le cégep?
- Oui, ah oui, complètement.
LUKA BORDELEAU, étudiant en
musique, cégep de Drummondville
ututututute notre arte, toute
la signification vient dans
le partage qu'on fait de notre
art avec le public puis avec nos
collègues. Alors, être tout seul
dans ma chambre, devoir rester
motivé à envisager une carrière
en musique, ce qui est déjà
assez courageux et téméraire!
- Officiellement, le nombre
d'échecs n'a pas augment
les cégeps, parce qu'au début
de la pandémie, le ministère
a permis les abandonààààà
la fin des cours. Cela permet
aux étudiants d'avoir un
incomplet au lieu d'un échec.
Ce sont donconononononons de
cours qui ont explosé de 500 %.
ALICIA ARCAND, étudiante en
musique, cégep de Drummondville
- Il ys s s s s s que j'ai
échoué une fois, puis c'était
parce que j'avais vraiment trop
de choses dans mon horaire.
p p p p p petite extension
avec quel degré?
MARIANNA SEPULVEDA, étudiante en
musique, cégep de Drummondville
- Mettons, en solfège, on est
moins loin que normalement.
Moi, je me disais : j'ai pas
envie de traîner de la
tout le long de mon université,
parce qu'on est un peu en
arrière à cause de ça. Donc,
j'ai décidé de prend
temps au cégep finalement.
FRANCIS GAGNON, professeur de
musique, cégep de Drummondville
- J'avoue quhahahahahahahant
d'entendre ça.
- Mais est-ce qu'ils vont
arriver avec en retard
à l'u
- C'est difficile à dire,
parce qu'il y a possibilité
de rattraper, puis au niveau de
l'ininininininine, de l'oreille
musicale, ça se développe à long
terme.
ÉRIC SAINT-JEAN, directeur des,t
- Il y a une anxiété chez notre
population étudiante.
Ils ont, à tort ou à raison,lals
de ne pas avoir tout ce qu'il
faut pour continuer.
- Autre cégep, autre programme,
d d d d d d d dans les
apprentissages. Les jeunes
arrivés du secondaire l'automne
dernier ont des retards marqués,
surtout en français, en
mathématiques et en sciences,
pour certains.
YOUNES SAÏDI, étudiant sciences
de la nature, cégep St-Laurent-t
beaucoup plus difficile.
J'ai beaucoup de retard et
j'arrive pas à rattraper mon
retard, donc je dois
plus.
- Plus de la moitié de l'année
en 5e secondaire s'est passée en
mode virtuel. Rendu au cégep,
les retards sont parfois
difficiles à rattraper,
même pour les bons étudiants.
ANTOINE GUIRGUIS étudiant scien.
nature, -L-L-L-L-L-L-L-Laurent
- La première session, c'était
"rusheuse". J'ai échoué quelques
cours, ça fait que je suis en
train de les reprendre.
- Et est-ce que c'était la
première fois que tu échouais
des cours?
- Oui.
- Oui. Ça fait que ça,
ça m'a pris par choc.
J'étais un peu en dépression à
cause de ça, mais c'est la vie.
- Je vais vous demander de venir
me voir avec votre tube,
de me le montrer.
- Barbara Augustin dit
qu'elle n'a
d'encadrement à faire. Les
étudiants sont désorganisés.
BARBARA AUGUSTIN, enseignante en
microbiologie, cégep St-Laurent
- eseseseseseseseses de mémoire
par rapport aux dates
d'échéance, comment s'organiser
avec les différents documents,
les différentes plateformes.ouot
la première fois en 15 ans
de carrière que je devais faire
autant de rappels et
d'accompagnement. t t t t t t ù?
- Ils sont là.
- Mets-les.
(rire)
- Gabriel Collin est revenu auc,
après trois ans sur le marché
du travail.
- C'est parfait, ça. Génial!
- Très motivé, il a
cours de chimie du secondaire
pour être admis en bioécologie.
Mais la COVID a cassé son élan.
GABRIEL COLLINC, étudiant
bioécologie, cégep St-Laurent
- Il y a un moment où je me suis
demandé : est-ce que je continue
vraiment ou non? Puis j'avais
vraimentenenenenenenenenenent
que la pandémie m'a fait douter
de savoir si je voulais
continuer encore avec
la scolarité.
- Dorothée Tanguay chante un
succès d'Aretha Franklin au
Festival ArtScène, or
chaque été par le cégep de
Drummondville.
- Je vais aussi apporter
mes livres de musique.
- La chanteuse va bientôt
partir planter des arbres
en Colombie-Britannique.
Après trois sessions en musique,
elle a craqué.
DOROTHÉE TANGUAY
- Je suis sesesesesesesesesesese
dépression, ça fait que...
Moi, je pensais pas que ça
allait m'arriver. Moi, je suis
un j j j j j j j j j j joyeuse
puis cette session-ci,
ça a tout lâché.
- Dorothée s'était bien ad
aux cours virtuels.  Le retour
en classe, l'automne dernier,
a été beaucoup plus difficile.
- Il y a eu un trè
achalandage.
- Les psychoéducateurs sont très
sollicités depuis septembre.  Le
retour en présen
sur le vaccin obligatoire ont
provoqué beaucoup d'anxiété.
MARC-ANDRÉ LEGRIS psychoéduc.
cégep de
- Il y a aussi la polarisation
en lien avec le statut vaccinal.
Certains étudiants s'inquiètent
çaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaçaça parce
qu'ils peuvent se faire refuser
des stages, perdre leur emploi,
remettre en question leurs......
- Dorothée, qui n'est pas
vaccinée, a vécu ce débat
comme une agression.nsnsnsnsnsns
une tache, des fois.
Je comprends pas. Le monde me
regarde puis là, ils sont commes
je trouve ça désolant.
Ça mis un bâton dans les roues.
Ça me fait "tac". Autantémémémée
physiquement, je suis épuisée.-s
pour reprendre des forces,
mais elle n'abandonne pas.
Elle espère reprendre ses études
quand les soubresauts
de la pandémie seront apaisés.
- Avoir mon diplôme, c'est une
réalisation vraiment importante.
- Gabriel, qui a failli
décrocher du cégep une deuxième
fois pendant la pandémie,
vient d'être accepté en biologie
à l'université.
- Je suis vraiment fier.
C'est sûr qu'avec en plus
l'an dernier, ça fait un défi
de plus qu'il y avait à
surmonter, mais je suis vraiment
fier d'avoir terminé.
- A court terme, c'est
difficile, c'est handicapant,
c'est envahissant, mais
généralement, à moyen et long
terme, on sort grandi de ça,
puis on est capable de faire
face à d'autres adversité,
parce qu'on a de l'expérienc
en arrière de nous.
On p